market update over the weekend so here
it is okay uh I want to talk about
Bitcoin back quite briefly because only
in a few hours I'm gonna post the useful
Sunday update that I've been posting
every Sunday for the last year and a
half so stay tuned for the Sunday update
but I want to give you a quick hint of
what I think of Bitcoin at least in the
mid term okay so far what I see here is
that we've been in a range for a month
you even had here deviation above the
rain size now price has broken out of
that range to the downside and price
action is looking quite British why well
basically because you have the breakout
to the downside and you are below the
daily 50 I mean we've had one two three
four five six daily counter closes below
the 50 I mean the daily timeframe which
is quite berries now let's see how
today's
daily candle closes okay it's looking
like it might close above it but we
still have many hours left okay
um we literally have eight hours instead
ago or seven hours so anything can
happen but that's something of concern
also we've had three weeks to the upside
testing the range lows as resistance
which is also not good so this could
signal that Bitcoin next direction
should be to the downside possibly
towards this potential support
I'm gonna go support by support so so
far what I can see is that if we fall
from here the next support or the next
potential support should be 20 28 300.
why why because we've had here this
resistance that was tested twice before
and now it could be tested as support if
we come here okay so that's the first uh
Target to the downside now if you fall
from here or you don't do a deviation
and you continue falling okay
then the next Target is going to be 25
800 as the range lows of this previous
range okay so that's what I think now I
wanted to mention that Bitcoin looks
like it wants to continue going down
four the simple reason that if you go
into the Bitcoin dominance right this is
a chart that has a very high correlation
with Bitcoin pretty much what has been
doing for uh the last
months years it's been to follow Bitcoin
okay so uh you can even see since
November Bitcoin has done at times two
um the Bitcoin dominance has also going
up quite aggressively okay now the thing
is we've been in this range for I think
it was two years yeah for two years and
here
in this place here uh we were talking in
this Channel about the idea of a breaker
to the upside because the price action
here doesn't look the same as before you
can see here
you go weeks and quick and quick
reactions okay
check this out
and in this Zone price is stabilized
a resistance okay so that could tell you
that okay this time is looking a bit
different we might see a breakout we had
a breakout during this time altcoins
many altcoins at least made a new lows
that's the truth uh and that's something
that I made a video talking about this
possibility of all coins making new lows
they made new lows now
what is going on with the Bitcoin
dominance Bitcoin dominance has been
falling same as Bitcoin has been now
dropping uh Bitcoin
and that has left room for outcomes to
continue going higher
okay and try to retrace a bit of those
imbalances that happen in this move
higher okay now what I think is that as
Bitcoin seems like he wants to go down
the most normal thing for the Bitcoin
dominance is to also continue going down
and hopefully test the rain size as
support okay so this previous resistance
soon
it might be the new support if that's
the case now imagine for a second that
the Bitcoin dominance comes here
Tesla support consolidates here in
support and Bitcoins continue falling
okay while the Bitcoin dominance is
holding here that's gonna be really bad
news for altcoins okay that's gonna be
really bad for altcoins on you're gonna
see again new lows so uh that's the only
scenario the and keeping in mind I wanna
see
a Bitcoin dropping from here
but again it's not because I'm
embarrassed on crypto or Bitcoin in the
long term not at all I'm in fact very
bullish in Bitcoin and all coins in the
long term so I want to get ready for the
next bull market so
um if this happened okay that if Bitcoin
goes down and you'll go down essentially
that's not a bad thing if you are
prepared okay because that means you're
gonna be able to buy cheap again all
right so uh this is one of sales and
keeping in mind to see Bitcoin dropping
maybe 28 25 22 who knows I'm the Bitcoin
dominance holding this previous systems
are support and that would mean that the
rest of the Alchemy Market is going to
continue dumping and many ankles are
gonna revisit the lows
that they made uh last month okay and
even make new looks uh so that's what I
think that could happen to all coins
essentially now if you go into the total
three
this is a chart
that uh puts together all the altcoin
market okay because it removes uh
Bitcoin and ethereum so this is what we
have okay
in my opinion we have here some kind of
a range
I don't know I lied to you to me this is
some kind of a wrenchia
okay let me remove the 50ma by the way
the 50ma in the weekly time frame
acted as resistance here
why not
resistance again okay I'm making a
little low because essentially this
are all the time new lows okay it's all
the time and you well lower highs okay
it's all the time lower highs so I think
that we are in this type of a range
and the only thing that
I don't like about this chart is this
and efficiencies imbalances here this
blue box
uh I think there is a chance that maybe
know everything maybe not all all of it
but at least partially gets filled okay
and that could mean maybe that you are
in a ranch here you might see another
drop okay this might be a deviation
and then price could continue going
higher the next year okay so that's a
possibility now the only thing that
could
invalidate this idea and that's
something that I'm open to is is this is
indeed
value information here
okay
gets back above the 50ma in the weekly
time frame test your support and that
could tell me okay uh this idea is
invalidated and we're gonna go higher
because yes we also of course have some
inefficiencies up here check out this
large red candle okay so that's my
validation well I think that something
like this
okay
it's more likely I think that's
something like that is more likely to
happen over the next months so uh that's
the reason why at the moment I might be
bearish in in altcoins and I'm not sure
that what we've seen last month was the
bottom of that Green Market
also if you go to the 2003
versus Bitcoin
right do I notice something here let me
remove this
all right there you go this is basically
the alcohol Market versus Bitcoin and
what is telling you is that since
November 2022 the alcoin market versus
Bitcoin has been dropping 50 percent and
the only reason why the alcohol Market
didn't go to the floor is because
Bitcoin is at times two
okay so what happens now if Bitcoin
drops and also the total three versus
Bitcoin continues losing value that's
also gonna be really bad for altcoins
okay so
um avaki a couple of support levels the
Orange Lines okay well I'm gonna change
into white so you can see them better
so these white lines are potential
supports
um potential buy zones for our coins
we see here that this one acted as
support then resistance so I think that
it will eventually come to these levels
I want to see a reaction here
okay if we don't see a reaction here
then it's going to continue dropping and
this is going to be really really bad
for all queens okay now do I expect the
article Market to come all the way down
here
uh I cannot tell you I don't have a
crystal ball I cannot tell you but we
must be prepared what I think is that is
very likely
that it comes to this level over here
okay I think that that's very lightly
and then here we'll see how it looks
okay if we see a deviation tested our
support like it happened here okay or
here although he actually didn't test
your support let me check
um quickly okay but if we said it's not
support like in this example I'm
bouncing then you know that's your
confirmation that we're gonna see a
bounce
maybe again to this house okay but so
far
what I see is uh
the alcohol Market looking quite bearish
and it can continue dropping low also
more efficiencies again on the way down
okay
So based on this uh what I mentioned
about Bitcoin uh possibility of
retracing lower the Bitcoin dominance
holding that previous resistance support
the total free and the imbalance below
it below the range and this chart dollar
three versus Bitcoin has still been able
to test this support Zone okay based on
This I Believe In The Narrative that the
alcohol Market is not out of the woods
yet and I don't believe that the bottom
is confirmed at least in the altcoin
market and we could still see lower
prices now if you don't believe on this
and and you deciding with me that's
absolutely fine okay you can start
buying now or when you want and then if
that happens you can DCA
that's also fine Bo me as a Trader I
still believe that this Market is more
for a Trader than for an investor at
least just yet okay if my invalidation
gets trigger of course I'll change my
mind above until that happens I still
gonna focus more on trades and if we see
uh drop lower that's what I'm looking to
become an investor or when I see
confirmation after one of my validations
I get triggered okay that's what I want
to say now we're going to go through
different all coins I I posted a tweet
yesterday and I was telling you that I
was going to make a video about the
alcohol Market tell me URL coins and I
had something crazy like 350 answers so
thank you very much this is why this
video is gonna be a bit longer than
usual I'm going to analyze I think it's
uh 12 Al coins the 12 alkins that you
mentioned the most they're gonna be
Solana chain link op Matic avax polkadot
Rose near Gala Dodge fat and a Vulcan
Forge
let's start with Solana
now Solana uh I think that during these
next month if I'm gonna tell you what I
what I'm going to do because I still
believe in the narrative the altcoins
are not going to do this from here okay
I don't believe that when I do this from
here I think the white estate in
accumulation soon and we might still do
something like this okay and then yeah
we can say the breakout Ballroom
um everybody getting rich okay of course
but based on this narrative that I
believe now I'm not asking you to agree
with me but based on this what I'm gonna
do now is I'm gonna go and research some
projects
um get the fundamentals look for new
tokens
of course charting I want to chart a lot
of altcoins in higher time frame like in
this video and what I believe in Solana
first of all I believe that it's a good
project the uh no only survive but also
Thrive okay and I think for example you
can easily I'm not gonna talk about what
can happen if we break at the highest
days uh 260 okay but I think for example
this level over here
dates around
135 35 ish I think that would be
average Target for Solana in the next
bull market very easy and of course
under this missing the idea of new highs
okay but we're gonna have this zone for
reference and as an investor
I think that we are in this range here
okay check out this range
so in my opinion this was support
this was support again support then we
break that support down resistance
resistance all right and here you have
resistance and support okay so in my
opinion we are in this range over here
now
if what I believe here is that we've
seen a deviation
right also we've had this week
um I believe that this week has been
filled at least 50 percent of it so no
imbalance at the highs now if we print
here
a lower high
okay that would be something like this
and test this soon as for instance again
then I'm going to consider the idea of
opening not showing short over here
maybe to this level over here that will
be the mid-range to 19 or 50 ish and a
stop loss above the range size okay so
maybe around here on this one uh just in
case uh that's a trade that I'm
considering for solenovel what I'm
mostly looking more into is buying
opportunities
um so in my opinion
I think that I'm going to become
a buyer all the time at this range lows
okay so that's around 14 to 50. if we
come again if we form this lower high
and we come again to this Zone
this in my opinion a good song to buy 14
to 50 and if we actually come lower
you have here this liquidity pool as
another potential DCA place
and of course this week are the lows now
this week I'm not sure if it's gonna get
filled 95 of weeks or so can filled now
could this be part of that five percent
of weeks why not because check this out
okay Ducati another week this one over
here
um the 50 of the week got filled exactly
and then we saw a bounce
um if you notice
that didn't quite happen there okay it
go maybe to like the 40 so could that be
enough maybe okay that's what I'm
telling you don't set all your bits at
the 50 of this week because I'm not sure
at all if you want to come here
uh the same as this liquidity pool so I
think that a good first place to DCA
would be at the range lows around 14.50
uh that would be almost a Time stand
from here okay to the range well sorry
from the range lows to this level over
here okay that's a times nine
right so that's a basic
charting that I've done in Solana
something that I believe it could happen
Okay lower high here
this could even be uh double information
okay lower high into this resistance
again and drop again to the mid-range
and if you break through the mid-range
then you have the range loss again and
that could be a good Buy in zone okay
but essentially what I'm looking for
projects like Solana is Sol more
consolidation okay I want to see more
consolidation here for a few more months
maybe even until literally I'm not even
joking why not the stars of 2024. okay I
know that some of you would go crazy
this and I have deviations here okay or
or even this way but essentially I'm
looking for more consolidation at the at
the bottom okay that's what I want to
see before the next like up at least to
this Target and why not new highs in the
let us every new bull market okay so
that's Solana
now let's go into the next coin now the
next coin is going to be chain link one
of my favorite coins okay I think he
moves very nicely and I can already see
this consolidation that I'm talking
about this consolidation we've been in a
combination for a year okay this is what
I like to see
in uh bear Market bottoms okay that's
what I like to see also we've been
talking quite loudly about this
potential deviation here to 480 I don't
know if you remember the previous videos
that we posted but that was based on the
idea that there was a liquidity pool
here at the left in the chart
there was this one check out this large
green candle okay and if we mark it
there you go
4.73.60 all right and it's perfectly
marking the bottom of well at least
temporary bottom of link so that's
um that's one of the evidence is
work very nicely they
retrace that imbalance to the dollar and
now it's bouncing back inside of range
usually
when you see a deviation here
by one ends of the range you'll see a
break at the other end again
with The Narrative of Bitcoin
I don't know what's going to have into
chain link okay I think that we are
still going to be inside this range for
quite some more time before we break out
okay but yeah if any of you caught the
Bison here
perfect I'm telling you that's I don't
think you could have got a better entry
than 480 okay 480 was absolutely perfect
also remember that we were mentioning
that this hat
um confluence
with these levels over here check out
this week so that could be a potential
support and it will apply nicely now if
we see
A Drop In Chain Link I'm still gonna
become a buyer that range slows if we
come again to this level also and if we
drop even lower why not to win three
dollars I'm also buying here okay I like
chain link it's making Partnerships with
a lot of projects so I think it's
fundamentally
a good project that I like okay and
again if you will for example imagine
a 480 or a five I don't care that the
highest is 50 okay if we revisit by the
high is that by the way there is a
liquidity pool over here right at the
top of the market for you this one oh
sorry uh what is my rectangle here this
one over here then that's essentially at
times 10 over there okay that's the time
stand there you don't have to look for
new micro cups
um the small altcoins you can just go
for other coins that you believe in do
you think that good projects and if you
buy at the absolute bottom or do you
mean at least that you're a bug in every
single dip that you're not buying this
dip diorama in this deep in this deep
okay all the time or this dip
um if you accumulate at the range loss
instead of buying these days because if
if not
then you drive with its entry price it
might be still around here okay and you
might still be negative
all right so if you accumulate the range
loss then you know only visiting again
the highs data times 10 which is quite
doable for any project
right so that's my chart for chain link
now op
let's go to op
I haven't done enough research of this
project
um I don't know if the fundamentals I
don't know if it's a good project or not
but many of you mention it so I'm gonna
have a look at it
um so far what I can see here is this
trend line okay and several weeks you
have this week over here
this week over here so it seems quite
difficult for me also if we check op
and we look for weeks
the quick start it has created okay like
for example this one over here this one
over here let's look for more this one
over here
uh there are many weeks to be honest but
the ones that they've created
they've been felt okay
they've been filled
even this one even the fifty percent
should be around here so ego field also
okay so they've been filled it moves
quite nice this coin to be honest other
than I've never tried this coin but it
moves very nicely okay so that's
obviously a coin that I'm gonna have for
my reader from now on
I'm gonna of course search the
fundamentals to see if it's a good if
it's a good project that I can buy for
the long term but what the chart is
telling me is that there are a couple of
weeks here at the lows that I think
they're gonna get filled if I'm honest
with you all right and also I think that
we're inside this range
to be honest with you
all right check out this range here it
reminds you of the of the range with
Bitcoin again you go here another week
another week you're getting here week so
the upside price not come no continuing
breaking to the upside large green
candles and weeks to the upside and then
you see
aggressive rejections okay this is
exactly the same as we've had on bitcoin
okay even a deviation the same price
action as Bitcoin that we've had very
recently so what I believe is that op is
set to maybe fill this week here and
then drop again to the range lows and
fill this all that week okay so if you
are a Trader I'm gonna look into this
kind of setup okay
market for you
something like this
all right this is the kind of setup
that I'm gonna look with Opie okay entry
at the 50 of this week for example
a stop above the rain size and then you
can put the take profit sorry at the 50
of this week another 100 of this week
okay so that's what I'm looking
as a Trader and as an investor
let me remove this
then I'll have to again to the Daily
time frame I think
that what we could see here is
consolidation
okay go back
and test this uh train line and let's
see what this from here okay if he
starts to break down then targets are
the 50 of this week that's 114 and
also
eight okay that's what I'm looking for
in op now usually let me tell you when
we see adrenaline you see price coming
to the train line coming to the train
and again could continue coming to the
trail number there is this one over here
let me Mark it for you
okay
anista if price can have
let me Mark it for you better if price
can do something like this
okay hang on that's no good
something like this
and half another push up from here
okay you have here the range flows on
the train line have another push higher
maybe you could even do a deviation
above 1.80 ish
and then break below the train line and
start to fill these weeks okay so those
weeks are what I will be looking to buy
op for the future for the longer term at
least
but again I will have to do some
research okay I think as a Trader this
coin it's looking great to be honest
um I'm actually generally going to have
a look okay at the setup that I material
in the foreign
develops but that looks like a good uh
it's a around 10 percent trade okay if
that happens so yeah that's what I think
of op
next coin Matic
okay let's go to Matic
all right
so with Matic
this coin is quite dramatic
cringe but anyway with Matic um we had
two potential support songs okay one of
them was this liquidity pool level
American from from when we've already
been above one dollar
and if you notice with that drop the
past month we came all the way to this
liquidity pool we retraced it fully even
a deviation below it and then price went
up okay so what I want to tell you is
that don't look for projects and buy
every single day because if you buy
every dip of mati then you would have
bought here to put a bot here you go to
bot here at 80
2 or 85 cents the root of Bot here okay
and at the end
let's say that your average entry or
your average entry would have been
around here okay but you still wouldn't
even get there to break even
all right so what you are again trying
to find are liquidity pools like for
example this one that we have here and
here yes you can buy a bag okay because
then you know that if you can hear
actually like we see a bounce you could
even sell now and take some profits or
if you want to leave it for the for the
longer rune that's fine set a stop loss
a break even and another bit lower don't
okay that's what I would do uh if I want
to buy Matic and the next Zone if he
continues going lower
is this liquidity pool over here uh
below well around 0.25 okay around 25
cents I know that would be a quite
brutal drop but to be honest here
there will be also some support
in this one here between 40 cents and 30
cents okay so again it could fall there
that could hold and never touch this
Equity pull but as the ultimate bison it
should be around 25 cents I don't I
don't see magic going lower than that
okay
but again I think I see Matic going to
40 30 cents I think that's quite likely
and revisiting this liquidity pool
why not I mean again this was here a
train line that creates liquidity you
keep touching the training and train and
then you have a spike up breakthrough
okay consolidate half another letdown so
uh in my opinion it's not looking good
for Matic
um I'm I'm not saying that I'm buying
Matic for the long for the long run
because I haven't done enough research
on this project uh although many of you
mentioned it so I'll have a look at it
but I'm looking more as a Trader here
with Matic okay again next project
a box
so let's get there
okay uh look I've already charted
previously
probably I believe the same let's have a
look
um it's not looking but at all okay it
may hear a new low
last month but to be honest it's not
looking bad again this is another range
okay it's looking exactly the same as
the total three
check this out
this is your range
okay that's your range
and I see accumulating here it looks
like
it looks like a good chart for a better
Market bottom to be honest because he's
accumulating here all the
um again I think that with the
narratives that I've been telling you
about the alkins could continue going
lower
I'm gonna be looking for a deviation
here that would be a nice buying Zone
around nine to fifty dollars and if we
draw below this level then you're gonna
go for the next report that is seven
dollars okay but if I'm betting in the
narrative that I've told you about
dalquins could continue going lower
I'm not buying
until we reach this level over here 950.
okay
um if you buy other range lows 1050 I
mean it's one dollar difference that's
fine although it's a 10 different but
again that's why safe in case you don't
see this deviation but I believe
the
the outcome Market hasn't bottom out yet
we might see another lockdown or new low
seven
even if we've made a new low but if you
notice here is making it's making lower
lows and if you check any altcoin versus
the Bitcoin pair
okay you're gonna notice that it keeps
going down okay this is not looking like
a combination so it keeps making new
lows all the time okay new lows new lows
new lows and the only thing the only
reason why
the the chart
with the dollar pair is holding is
because Bitcoin has done at times two
since November otherwise our avax and
many other projects
would already be a seven dollars
all right now imagine what would happen
if Bitcoin drops at the same time
as avax versus the Bitcoin
continuous dropping and also Bitcoin is
dropping okay that would mean that avax
in the dollar pair
would make new lows and it would go to
9.50 and seven dollars okay so those are
my two buying zones for a box if
what I'm talking about actually happens
next coin polka dot
let's check portal
again it's looking exactly the same
as a total free which is good okay I
like the coins that follow the total
three now
I see again my validation here very
clear W formation
breakup of the 50ma test their support
and then I'm buying this confirmation
okay uh I wouldn't be buying a five I'll
be buying a seven but you know I'm
buying a confirmation at least
um that would still give me some profits
okay but eventually
until that gets proven until proven
otherwise
could continue going lower because I
think that this it's literally
a new low okay if you check that
that's a new low right again it might
have been a sweep of the lows and then
you see that the information playing out
but
um also you can see here lower highs all
the time
okay so I think that why not why not
tell me why polkadot couldn't drop to
this potential Support over here okay
and that's between
3.83 and 3.60 that's my bison for
polkadot okay
next one rose
I've done some researchers on this
project I like this project I can tell
you the elephants okay this product is
good utility I like it but again it's
making lower highs
here
here here
now I have another bounce I'm expecting
the fifth cm into Jesus resistance again
okay another lower high another drop all
right do you see what I mean
um so let me see what I have Mark here
daily time frame
okay I guess this was a support level
support there
fine
let me remove the liquidity pool that I
marked partially filled the 50 of it has
been filled that's good
so I think that with rose
the
other one so
let me try to mark
arrange
I think something like this with my
range okay I still think that
it could come
Maybe
to this Zone over here okay this one
over here is the zone that I could buy
rows Could It Go lower
let me check
this is what I do when I go into a chart
okay
um
no I like this Zone I think that
maybe not make new lows but why not
revisiting these ones from December 2022
okay and that would be around
three cents and a half ish all right I
like this Zone here
um yep that's what I think of rose
and I want to see how much potential it
got
weekly time frame
okay wow it reached actually 60 cents
so that will be a times 20. all right so
buy in here
that's a times 15
all right
um yep and also I see here some
liquidity pools okay advice wow
right at the high there is a liquidity
pool I like when I see that because this
liquidity pools they give me a lot of
Confluence the price
it should revisit these Heist again okay
um
I still have to do some more research
about this because I know the binance
holds a massive back of rows
um I'm usually I don't like when I when
um one company or one person holds a big
bag of the same
token but I think balance holds if I
remember correctly are a huge load of
roads which that's something that could
put me off a bit okay I would have to
check the cones and prawns of that but
it's I think it's as a project the
fundamentals are like them okay I would
become a buyer
in this one over here so that would be
around
0.037
and then why not carry all the way for a
times 10 times 13 times 15 why not I
think it's a good project okay that's
what I think of rows let's check near
now
okay
have I marked here
okay I guess that I've marked this
potential range
then we have this resistance here
so let's go into daily time frame and of
course this liquidity pull low okay
so
okay let me check oh here is looking
better
um these are huge accommodation sun is
very very wide okay
because this accommodation zone is
literally
128 28 okay
um
I'll tell you
I don't see most of an accumulation
going on here at the moment yet
I think that what I would like to see
with near
is to see more consolidation here
that's what I would like to see okay
then again thinking that the alcohol
Market could again make new lows
this one over here so be quite
interesting Zone okay I don't think
naniard would go below one dollar
if I'm honest with you
um because I think that this is one of
the coins that investors are gonna Place
their bids below one dollar they're
gonna wait oh if it goes below one
dollar then I'm buying loads so I think
that based on that I don't think here
it's gonna go to one dollar okay I think
it's gonna stay above it I mean below
one dollar I think it's gonna stay above
one dollar maybe one dollar five
1.010 something like that okay I will
become a buyer but I would like to see
some more consolidation
maybe here okay then test this Zone here
buy there
or maybe that you can start to see
um
some kind of rally
uh but yeah I think it needs more
consolidation this token but the chart
is to me looks good as long as I see
liquidity pools are the highs okay like
for example this one at ten dollars so
if I buy then at 1.05 and I sell at 11.
that's another times 10. and now and I'm
not even betting are the highest okay
because the highest is
at twenty dollars so that will be at
times 20. all right within here so
that's what I see with near I don't
think it's gonna fall below one dollar
and I want to see some more
consolidation and a bison would be here
between 1.05 and 1.10
next coin
um which ones you told me I have here
notebook sorry
The Notebook that died that I dropped in
a previous video uh it's quite useful
Gala let's check Gala
okay uh
again I have to do some more research
about this project
but so far
far
this drop what happened here
this drop is crazy so it went from 0 to
80.
to 0.015 wow that's that's brutal that's
really brutal and in the daily time
frame
I don't like this pump
very aggressive
then consolidate cannot break above with
those weeks so you see price recovering
these imbalances
I'm not I'm not really a fan of this
chart at the moment okay I still think
that has he retrace this liquidity pool
yep absolutely
to the dollar
wow all right that was cool uh so this
liquidity pool here this whole pump has
been retraced which is good but I think
that there now this week here
should get retraced next all right
um that would be
the 50
around 0.0 19 below 2 cents okay I think
Aladin is gonna go there
if I'm honest with you
that's the level that I think that is
going
and again I would like to see some more
consolidation with yellow all right I
would like to see something like this a
bit more
but yeah I think that if I buy below two
cents
um there are plenty of liquidity pools
here to be honest you've got one here
one here one here one of the highs so
let's say the Dubai are two cents
um do you sell for example at
I don't know even here around 30 cents
that's a Time 16.
wow
okay these are probably done I'm gonna
do some research
uh it looks good it looks like a good
bull market coin I think it's a gaming
coin if I'm if I'm correct okay but what
I would like to see some more
consolidation fill this week in the
daily time frame
okay so that's a label that I would buy
but again I want to see some more
consolidation okay give me some kind of
uh of a range here
or something okay I want to see some
more consolidation here please and then
fill this week and I'm ready for the
bull market with discount okay that's
what I think of Gala I need more
research
next one
Dodge
I think it's quite an interesting chord
I'm gonna tell you why I think we all
know that it's useless it's pointless
it's a meme coin it has no utility Bo
is the coin of Elon Musk so let's see
what he pretends to do with Twitter now
called X I think that his idea is to to
create some kind of like a WeChat I
don't know if you guys know what WeChat
is in China
uh I think it does his idea because he
mentions that he mentioned that he wants
X to have at least half of the Global
Financial system so that would allow
transactions could they be with Dodge
Coin Dodge
so
uh that's literally the only thing that
I like about Dutch the reason that I
like about Deutsche is that Elon Musk
has well locks the project and he would
put money into this so uh that could a
favor is gonna go higher okay
now if I look
at the chart
what I see here is uh quite important
support level over here okay that's this
Orange Line does support active support
here and what I don't like is that the
daily sorry the weekly 50ma does this
purple line is acting as resistance and
it's rejecting price
to come lower so why not could we see
something like this okay
some
tightening before expansion
what do you guys think
uh that's what I will be looking into
Dodge Coin because this would also be a
lot of consolidation this would give me
a consolidation range to be honest check
this out
this here would be your range lows
your range size could be there for
example
let me remove this okay and this would
give you
I mean it to me looks like accumulation
phase to be honest all right now I would
like to see one is Spike logo again into
the into this zone so that's exactly
right below five cents okay which is a
big drop from here and what I like to do
is uh 35 percenter from here so right
below five cents I think that if this
one holds or even make a deviation here
okay so that will be below around 4.5
0.045 I mean and then get back bull
market send this higher why not okay uh
that's what I think about Dodge Coin
will I buy Dodge Coin
I don't know I haven't asked that
question to myself yet uh
I would have to see how the chart looks
and
but I tell you I don't dismiss the idea
of buying some Dodge why not okay but I
would like to buy
around well below five cents or even in
this deviation here okay
something like that I would like to buy
but definitely not yet not that eight
cents maybe I regret in the future but
that's what I see for those definitely
interesting coin next coin you only have
two more to go we have
fat
let's get there
bye again this is another alcohol that
have to do some more research I see many
people talking about it I think it's um
with artificial intelligence
if I'm correct yeah AI artificial
intelligence which is quite interesting
because you guys know how artificial
interest is doing now is the new thing
okay so let me think so far what I see
here
is this trend line
that is being respected so far and I see
this
a potential support Zone you can see how
it was a resistance for
basically
wow six months okay and he never got
tested as support so why not could we
see fat coming lower test this
resistance as support at the same time
as it tasted this trend line
okay around here if the timing is
correct so that's around 10 cents
and then from here you have the bull
market okay and of course I would expect
this coin to make new highs of course
maybe even three four five dollars okay
so uh why not I have to do some more
research about this going to see uh if
he's doing any partnership or was there
uh business projections what they what
they are trying to accomplish but if it
gets to this Zone
and it holds a support I'm definitely
buying here but again that's a very
heavy drop of almost 50 percent and with
artificial intelligence so strong at the
moment I don't know if it's gonna get
there although to be honest it's been
dropping already
let me check it's already dropped at 70
percent
same February so why not another you
know 50 from there uh if he gets here to
0.11 0.10 I'm buying here I'm buying
here for sure all I have to do some more
reaches but the chart I will buy it the
chart looks great to be honest
um that's what I think
for this project okay CW 11 0.10 next
one
uh I think this one is a Vulcan Forge
let me check
the Vulcan Forge let's go to this chart
of cocoin
okay this coin is clearly in an
accumulation phase
now I think that correct me if I'm wrong
I have to do some more research I think
it's a gaming
token right I think it's uh for gaming I
haven't seen I haven't seen the game yet
I don't know how it looks if it looks
good how many uses it has if it's been
listed in any platform like epic games
or steam or any of these platforms so I
have to do some more research about
borkan Forge okay but yeah just looking
at the chart
over the next month maybe make a video
talking about the outcomes that I'm
gonna buy for the next bull market you
know maybe like a top a list of 10 or
yeah five or ten particles that I that I
will buy for the next Bull Run okay that
could be a good video uh but so far just
by looking at the chart and without
doing much research I think that this is
an accumulation phase
again I would like to see something
similar to chain link and that would
mean add deviation below the range lows
so that would be around
maybe 2-50 2.30 okay and then from there
it can uh go high okay something like
this uh so I'm not gonna buy in this
range I think let's see how the next
months go but I would definitely expect
to buy somewhere like a deviation here
and of course only in a spot okay or
everything that I've talked is in in a
spot except the short in the potential
short I think it was in op
um I think that was the only trick that
I was talking about the rest are also
are only sport opportunities so yeah
around 2.30 give me a deviation get back
inside the range test it as support if
possible if not you know get back into
the range
um here we buy into okay and that would
make that would take me if I'm buying
around 2.50
um it takes me check this out okay you
got liquidity pool
here
and you got one here a smaller one but
you got one here at the heist okay so
that could give you another times 10 in
the bull market all right
um what I'm saying is of course
in case you don't know say that you put
uh 1K
so do we got the end of the ballroom 10K
all right that's what I'm standing you
would do a times 10 of your original
entry okay uh so yeah that's basically
what I think of those alkoons uh I think
that they were more Alchemists are
dimension for sure but I've gone for the
ones that you mentioned the most now if
you want a second part of this video I'm
gonna see if you guys liked it if you
think that it was useful
um and if so I'll make a second part of
this video with different all coins
um you have to remember that I might be
wrong here
um if we go to doll three okay this is
the again
the chart that puts all the altcoins
together even the exceptions okay
they're here if I'm wrong then we'll see
here
a double information give me a leg
higher
break above the weekly 50 May test data
support and then I'll tell you here yep
I was wrong and then we're gonna go high
okay and that's your bull market uh
that's what I think okay but I'm still
believing in the in the idea that this
chart is making lower highs
all the time you can check this okay and
I also have an efficiency here under the
Bitcoin dominance
should drop because Bitcoin is dropping
but Bitcoin could drop more the Bitcoin
dominance has here potential support
that it could hold and that would mean
that basically
the outcomes would bleed would get
wrecked okay and I'm not talking to you
about 20 percent getting wrecked I'm
talking to you about getting wrecked by
40 30 some coins 50 percent
okay that's still possible even if
Bitcoin doesn't make any looks which I
think that uh it's possible that the
bottom of Bitcoin is in okay I'm not
asking for a new Bitcoin bottom at all
but I think that uh the altcoin market
might not have bottom out yet okay so
based on this Theory these are my buy
zones now don't get offended if you've
already have some coins okay and do
watch this video on do you feel angry or
sad because I'm telling you that they
might still go lower uh ticket as an
opportunity because now you might be
prepared after watching this video you
might have DCA lower all right so yeah
be open-minded
um
everything in crypto is possible this is
my beliefs I think that it's likely
the total three comes to this uh
imbalance around two
130 240 billion market cap and that
would bring the alcohol Market down with
it all right you might see new lows
better about your opportunities and
again if you bought here
that's fine you can buy again here
cheaper okay and then your average it's
gonna be lower so for the next Ballroom
you know you have to weigh less to make
to be in profit okay or if it goes as it
goes High they're gonna be more profit
because you have its entries here or
here are not here right so you profit
here it's gonna be higher so that's
pretty much everything guys I hope that
you liked the video and I'll see you
soon